do you think
psychedelics that i just mentioned
earlier have a
possibility of going
to these kind of same kind of
places of exploring ideas that are
outside of our
um more commonplace understanding of the
world
um in my yeah i think so absolutely
however i think we have to be really
careful about
those because young people or people in
general i should say
absolutely can get hurt by them i mean
but we get hurt by alcohol
you know we drive our cars and we get
kill each other
but psychedelics are really interesting
because i know that
within the history of of our country
um we have used psychedelics in various
capacities for our military
in order to try to stimulate ideas and
access
places and information that can't be
accessed
normally this is all fact yeah
i talked to matt for like four hours so
we ran out of time being able to talk
but i wanted to talk to him about
mk ultra and um ted kaczynski there's so
many
mysterious things there there's like
layers of
what's known and what's not known it's
fascinating but i think what is
interesting is uh psychedelics were used
that were attempted to be used as
tools of different kinds that's the
point so like
we think of technology as tools
uh to enable us to do things in that
same way that
psychedelics like many drugs could be
used as tools some more effective than
others
absolutely i don't think what you i'm
not sure what you can do effectively
um with alcohol although
somebody i think somebody commented
somewhere on social media that
i don't know why everyone gives is so
negative about alcohol
because uh i think the person said that
um
it's given me some of the most
incredible it enabled me
uh to let go and have some of the most
incredible experiences with friends in
my life
and it's true we kind of sometimes say
alcohol is dangerous
it can make you do but the reality is
it's also
a fascinating tool for letting go
of trying to be somebody maybe that
you're not
and allowing you to be yourself fully in
whatever crazy form that is
and allow you to have really deep and
interesting experiences with those
you love so yeah even alcohol can be
used as an effective tool for
exploring experiences and becoming uh
expanding your mind and becoming a
better person
so what the hell was i talking about
uh so yes so so psychedelics and oh yeah
and mk ultra is there something
interesting to say in the
in our historical use of psychedelics
i mean think about it when did we start
doing that when did we start using those
that's true it's quite a long time ago
right
but okay but true but when did our
government start
experimenting with them with us okay our
government is the united states
government yeah
okay so that happened in around the
1950s
okay after quote unquote the 1940s
where we have 47 and we have you know
this
you know this roswell type stuff going
on okay
like crash sites and things like that so
i think that um
i think there might be a correlation
there i don't know what it is
okay but i do think fascinating actually
yeah there's
a lot of interesting things started
around that time
yeah yeah and so aldous huxley would say
we opened the doors of perception
okay and what flew in
[Laughter]
oh man that was beautifully put
you